entre los edificios destruidos por los
bombardeos y los árboles secos un parque
infantil es el único vestigio de color
que queda en este barrio de mariupol en
la ciudad sitiada por los rusos en
ucrania todos parecen conocer a alguien
que ha muerto más brujo el 16 de marzo
nuestro amigo conducía un auto y una
bala le alcanzó la garganta cinco
minutos después ya no estaba con
nosotros yo iba con él en ese auto le
llevé a casa pudo cambiar de asiento eso
fue lo último que hizo cuando regresamos
ya se había ido
para los que han logrado sobrevivir a
los bombardeos la vida en mariupol no es
fácil este grupo de jubilados come lo
que encuentra por la ciudad uno de ellos
víctor cocina para todos
cocinamos lo que encontramos entre los
vecinos un poco de col un poco de papas
hemos encontrado hasta pasta de tomate y
algo de remolacha
cuando suena la alarma de bombardeo se
esconden en el sótano
hemos luchado por nuestro bienestar pero
ahora somos pobres como perros de pie
junto al fuego sin hogar cuantos tiempo
va a durar no tenemos donde ducharnos
estamos bebiendo agua de dios sabe dónde
y qué tipos de bacterias tiene bueno no
es vida para una jubilada
a pesar de que mariupol es una ciudad
con corredor humanitario establecido
este ha funcionado intermitentemente y
muchos siguen atrapados allí